this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys michael here if you're
like us you might find yourself using
comedy as a coping mechanism to deal
with an increasingly chaotic world and
you might have noticed that for the past
few years the humor you're seeing is
getting well
kind of weird
online internet that is to say both the
style and the substance of lots of
recent comedy has become increasingly
adapted to the rhythms and patterns both
comedically and psychologically of the
extremely online are you happy nadine
you killed the dog meanwhile shows just
outside the mainstream like the eric
andre show
who killed hannibal or i think you
should leave with tim robinson have
reached a much larger audience through
their appropriation as memes you
probably love your mother-in-law with
tim robinson's we're all trying to find
the guy who did this becoming a
particularly ubiquitous figure in the
internet's collective lexicon indeed
it's even used by famously unfunny
political journalists what well close
our eyes just take your car and get out
of here
uh i love that show and i love that
sketch but what is this comedic style
where did it come from why does it make
us laugh and above all what does the
rise of extremely online humor tell us
about the world let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on how the internet
changed comedy
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn surfsharkvpn helps you
secure your data with industry-leading
measures by using uncrackable encryption
and the most secure vpn protocols
something i love about surfshark is how
it lets me check out content from around
the world that i otherwise wouldn't be
able to access normally i would just
have to read about some amazing new
absurdist comedy only available in the
uk but with surfsharkvpn i can just use
one of their servers to log into bbc
iplayer no problem and let the weird
british sitcoms wash over me you can
unlock the 15 largest netflix libraries
around the world and when you're
traveling abroad you can keep up with
all your favorite shows back home it's a
content connoisseur's dream one
subscription will allow you to protect
all your favorite devices and there are
apps for all your favorites like pc mac
android chrome firefox amazon fire stick
and even your xbox and playstation
surfshark is fast easy to use and jam
packed with features if you use the link
in the description and use the promo
code wisecrack you can get surfsharkvpn
for 83 percent of its normal annual
price plus three extra months for free
go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show to figure out how online
humor crossed over to our television
screens let's start by looking at i
think you should leave and determine why
watching it feels a lot like being on
the internet jizz
like shot you can say that cause you say
we can say whatever the hell we want
most obviously it's the content a lot of
the sketches are explicitly about online
experiences like crafting
self-deprecating comments on instagram
okay so cute look what i just posted
eating crap with these sacks of sh if
they died tomorrow no one would shed a
tear or trying to find that perfect
youtube video to share with your
co-workers it's fine if you like don't
have one i have one
you all have one i have one but there's
more the typical i think you should
leave sketch proceeds according to a
pretty reliable logic a character will
do something stupid or get something
wrong or be called out in some way oh
looks like you push
oh no it does both
what it does both i was here yesterday
it actually goes both ways and rather
than blushing or even apologizing they
just keep on doubling down
at first glance this may sound like the
structure of your typical comedy sketch
a character does a normal thing but in
an absurd way this then escalates until
a witty line or surprising reveal ends
the sketch but there's a crucial
difference on an snl sketch there might
be some genuine laughs but it's unlikely
to subvert or disrupt your expectations
all right well if you would come with us
we'd like to run some medical tests just
so you guys know some of the bruises on
mckeester were there before the aliens
in contrast on i think you should leave
characters start out with a logic that
is immediately baffling and often
incomprehensible and just continue to
double down completely unaffected by the
reactions of others and these sketches
disrupt our passive enjoyment here comes
big waves
it's this unlogic that propels the
famous hot dog guy sketch everybody
knows the guy in the hot dog suit has
crashed his hot dog shaped car into the
shirt store but he just keeps asking or
we could work as a team find out whoever
did this and punish him ourselves this
doubling down phenomenon mirrors a very
particular internet era way of being
these characters have resonated so much
in part because they feel so internety
like the sort of people who post
something ridiculous or offensive on
social media get some negative pushback
and then simply will not let it go these
are the social media happy folks who
destroy their promising career as a
young adult novelist because someone
getting paid minimum wage at starbucks
slightly flubbed their order or the kind
of dude who accidentally share some porn
and then loudly insist that they were
hacked in short they are the sort of
people who in the words of one famous
twitter poster are screaming i'm not
owned i'm not owned until they shrink
into a corn cup perhaps the most
clear-cut example of this sort of
behavior is the sketch in which a guy
kept awake by a baby on a flight decades
ago ends up pursuing vengeance upon said
baby until that baby is a grown man and
now
i will exact my revenge
i'm gonna cry
the whole
flight but i think you should leave is
far from the only example of an
extremely online comedy show the
producers of the eric andre show have
explicitly stated that the series is
supposed to reflect the frenetic
distribution of information on the
internet this helps explain why the show
is so consistently deranged and
disorienting it's why eric andre like an
angry reply guy keeps turning on guests
as if at the flick of a switch so you
gotta help me out okay do you understand
what i'm saying normal talk shows flow
roughly according to the rhythm of a
conversation the eric andre show flows
according to the rhythm of a social
media timeline if jimmy fallon lets you
turn your brain off as you fall asleep
eric andre keeps you alert because you
don't know what in the fresh hell might
happen next another extremely online
comedian is tim robinson collaborator
connor o'malley who you might recognize
from his disturbing vine videos 4 20.
he's since carved out a brilliant niche
on youtube securing the political affect
of prime social media targets from
online conspiracy theorists for right
over here i run truth hunters.com the
only news organization for those who are
woke to the obsessive fans of centrist
politicians mr howard schultz please i
need you i need you to come be president
for me to people inventing new
cryptocurrencies in contrast to robinson
and andre o'malley's work doesn't
satirize the internet so much as it does
embody the twisted psyches of those a
little too steeped in internet culture
this is my number nine spot the upside
down white house this is basically what
i think politics is in one video new
jersey's self-styled number one
masturbator must balance a dream trip to
the adult video awards with the news of
his grandfather's stroke i can't come
home this is like my mecca this is i
saved up so much money to come here so
where does this recognizable brand of
internet humor even come from in large
part the style was first devised by a
largely anonymous group of internet
users associated with the weird twitter
community in the late aughts and early
2010s most obviously the aforementioned
drill the comedy these users developed
feels very online most obviously because
it was developed on the internet but
also because it helped define our online
lexicon from drill alone we got concepts
like the aforementioned corn cobbing or
the racism dial or spending less on
candles but this type of internet humor
also has its origins and the seminal tim
and eric awesome show great job whose
amateurish style reflected the
unpolished public access television it
was parodying and i wanna
come up with a word and then we're going
to do a free association of the word it
also skewers things like the pro style
of spam emails and i'm here to talk to
you today about a simple medical
procedure that you might have heard
about or the goofily weird aesthetics of
early memes white rice fake
at the most basic level extremely online
humor has become a thing for a pretty
straightforward reason since its
invention in the early 90s the internet
has come to permeate every aspect of our
lives and good comedy is always going to
reflect the world as comics themselves
actually experience it seen from this
perspective it should actually be much
more surprising that there are so many
enduringly popular comedy shows where
the internet is either pretty much
non-existent or incidental people who
came of age before the internet simply
didn't live or think in the same way in
contrast extremely online humor is a
response to the new patterns of thought
both enabled and encouraged by this now
ubiquitous tool but to really make sense
of how extremely online humor works as
well as what it's ultimately trying to
achieve we need to look back to an
earlier attempt to make art that
reflected the rhythms and compulsions of
contemporary life epic theater as
practiced by the marxist playwright
bertolt brecht in 1920s and 30s berlin
according to brecht traditional dramatic
theater encouraged audiences to identify
with the characters as depicted leading
to emotional catharsis while he was more
thinking of say shakespeare than the
office or friends the effect is
ultimately the same when we watch these
shows we root for jim and pam like their
old friends and we debate whether we're
a ross a chandler or a joey but brecht
thought this effect was dangerous
because our over-identification with
characters ends up mystifying and
obscuring some essential truth see
brecht a classic marx bro worried that
audiences would over identify with the
rich and powerful and that this would
obscure the oppressive exploitative
property relations between characters
kind of like how all the characters and
friends can afford to live in manhattan
while around half of them are at any
given time unemployed this gives the
audience a deeply inaccurate picture for
what life for unemployed 30-somethings
in a major city is actually like it
leads to things like o'malley's vine
characters cycling through new york city
calling guys inexpensive cars pimps who
won at the game of life what's up pam
hey man what's up epic theater in
contrast employs what brecht called the
alienation or distancing effect in order
to create a sense of separation between
the audience and the action the
alienation effect distances the audience
from the characters in action so that
they can't over identify with any other
alienating techniques might include
breaking the fourth wall to address the
audience directly which makes it more
difficult for everyone to suspend their
disbelief other techniques include
employing sudden jumps or montages to
prevent the action from flowing as
expected using very bright or harsh
lighting and using songs to interrupt
the action friday
night
i'm thinking that we
just might or you know wishing death on
a baby i hope you
die
as you can imagine this often leads to
some pretty wild swings and emotional
tone this is fitting in the 1920s and
30s brecht was responding to a modern
world in which life seemed to have been
dizzyingly and indeed traumatically sped
up after all within living memory people
would transition from a world in which
nothing was electrified and barely
anyone had access to indoor plumbing to
one in which people were listening to
the radio it was also the night that the
skeletons came to life
going to the cinema we're gonna be so
early for that movie i'm not going to
the movie
what and driving cars i'm driving my
classic cars all the time it's just me
and the open road and all the while
being bombarded by advertisements
[Music]
sort of like the whiplash older
millennials who didn't have high speed
internet until they were teenagers now
experienced as they access every song in
existence on the same magical device
they use to track their health play
scrabble with strangers and find sexual
partners every one of you that used to
have an aol account knows exactly what
i'm talking about so feel free to post
your old instant messenger usernames in
the comments the idea behind the
alienation effect was to jolt audiences
out of this haze and help them think
critically about their own economic and
social situation this effect is
successful when it takes the usual and
familiar presents it in a different
light and thus makes it strange
extremely online comedy employs a
version of the alienation effect as well
just as breck's alienation effect helped
audiences think critically about the
world in his time extremely online humor
helps audiences consider what the
internet is doing to us today and i
think you should leave characters often
act like internet reply guys or trolls
in real life situations typically
becoming increasingly angry and
incoherent as they attempt to make their
incomprehensible why the [ __ ] would you
die on this hill point it costs more
because of the pattern yeah and
rightfully so meanwhile conor o'malley's
vines achieve a similar alienation
effect but by very different means his
videos are mostly filmed from the point
of view of his madman character so the
audience rarely actually sees him
instead we bear witness to the
disruptive effect he's having on actual
people and because the videos are all
only six seconds long the staccato
montage vibe means we never really get
any true sense of what it is like to be
him either both cinematic strategies
effectively raise the question
why do people act so nuts online what
are we all so angry about and what does
this say about us and o'malley heightens
this by showing what internet psychosis
looks like embodied in human form as for
the eric andre show its frenetic style
seems obviously wired to produce an
alienating effect sometimes indeed the
lighting the show employs is so weird
that it literally starts falling from
the ceiling
and in general the set seems like it's
made of cardboard knives and low-grade
explosives or take another lesser-known
but extremely online parody talk show
connor o'malley's lake talk show the
action which takes place in a lake is
frequently intercut with scenes in which
the waterborne host appears to be
struggling and drowning this mimics the
very real experience of being online
where we're confronted and yet alienated
by both the pain and the hubris of so
many strangers we can also see this in a
sketch from i think you should leaves
patty harrison whose job is tables how
is tables a job it starts with a
relatable premise we meet a shy girl who
is afraid to sing a song at karaoke
night i'm not some pop star super singer
and just
me sounds like a viable plot for a
network sitcom or rom-com right but then
harrison takes the stage and well
this happens
her song is basically a bunch of
right-wing tweets set to a dance beat
and at the end we learned that her beer
was actual [ __ ] the second harrison
sings
i love celebrities because they keep me
safe we are immediately distanced from
what's happening we're no longer
emotionally enjoying a funny sketch i am
11 years old
we're thinking about what she's saying
and why it makes us feel shocked or
uncomfortable rather than being
enjoyable the sketch turns
confrontational
brecht who is also 11 would be proud and
while we'd love to tell you to follow
harrison on twitter to see how she uses
the internet to create comedic
alienation we actually can't because she
was permanently banned for impersonating
the official nilla wafers account to say
things like if you're bisexual we don't
want your business this might seem like
a highly specific totally wild way to
get banned but it also forces you to
reflect on why we treat it as normal
when brands like oreos wade into sexual
politics on twitter or why it's somehow
important to us that the multinational
corporations responsible for our high
cholesterol share hot takes that align
with our moral and political beliefs and
of course once we stop to think about it
it becomes obvious how empty and cynical
these gestures are so thank you for your
sacrifice patty and this is why even the
most bizarre and initially
incomprehensible acts of internet humor
can actually be seen as a critical
response to the new patterns of thought
and behavior that have been normalized
by the world wide web comedians like
o'malley and harrison along with shows
like i think you should leave in the
eric andre show use brechtian methods to
create internet humor that ideally can
jolt audiences out of their
timeline-obsessed brains but there's one
more layer brecht wanted his theater to
serve as a political tool back in an age
where global revolution seemed like it
might really happen he hoped his plays
would inspire his audience to believe
that another world is possible now
obviously we're not arguing that
contemporary online comedy is trying to
start the revolution but does it at
least kind of hint at the descent that
brecht hoped for maybe extremely online
humor certainly helps us to understand
the internet like any good satire it
presents us with a more extreme version
of our lived reality and this extreme
distillation of our world helps us see
that reality for what it really is in
their different ways these comedians all
isolate some troubling aspect of our
individual or collective behavior our
trolliness our obsession with
mind-numbing talk shows or how
late-stage capitalism has turned our
cities into corporate-sponsored
role-playing games then it reflects it
back to us for laughs sure but also for
that excruciating feeling of recognition
it's what sam anderson of the new york
times calls ugly comedy for our ugly
moment internet humor also gives us a
language with which we can critique the
sinister infrastructure behind our
screen based reality and this is what
our favorite memes do for instance when
someone shares the hot dog guy meme they
identify a particular sort of
hypocritical behavior imagine an energy
company virtue signaling over their
investment in green power while they
themselves continue to burn fossil fuels
and even though these comedians are well
to the left of your average american
patty harrison even tweeted that she
would personally suck you if you voted
for bernie they're probably not about to
tell you to rise up and overthrow the
government indeed by focusing for the
most part on how strange and baffling
the world is right now their work is
much more likely to leave one feeling a
sort of
dumeris despair clearly something must
be done
but nothing really can
every massive climate rally organized by
hopeful teenagers is still being drowned
out by the handful of companies steadily
destroying the planet this is another
aspect of our contemporary affect when
we're living on a pretty aggressively
overheating planet during actual plague
times with the augmented cynicism fueled
by internet content even the idea of
trying to make positive change can feel
embarrassingly sincere so while these
comedians unlike brecht might not intend
for their sketches to inspire you to
fight the power and change the world
they just might be able to help us see
the world for what it really is and
because the world has increasingly
become an ever expanding web of
sponsored content farms social media
timelines and digital workspaces they're
using the culture of the internet to
show us just how ridiculous our lives
have become and also they're all really
[ __ ] funny i can't even watch a movie
anymore without a big pour of wine and
popcorn but what do you guys think is
extremely online comedy the key to
understanding the contemporary world or
is it just a bunch of fun and dumb
inanity can watching tim robinson and
eric andre enlighten us or will you just
end up regurgitating the premise of an i
think you should leave sketch at parties
like an idiot character later to be
played by tim robinson let us know in
the comments big thanks to our patrons
for all your support hit that subscribe
button like it's on sale at dan flashes
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you